boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don Satya we
are still at qoph as the Congress on the
future of engineering software for our
second annual partnership with them we
are not speaking with Elizabeth Barron
hello hello it's so great to be here
Alan thanks for coming on to our show
really appreciate it we're very excited
to talk to Elizabeth yes thirty-one
years at Ford she is immersive visionary
champion of the world I love it I'm very
excited to talk to you about this her
newest company Immersion airy is refresh
2019 started yeah and we'll be talking
about that and the importance of this
this this 3d storytelling the user
experience of that and the awareness
expansions that we can get from that and
the purpose of it all this good stuff
before we get there Elizabeth teach us
about your journey how did you get to
where you are today how do you even get
excited about engineering yeah isn't it
crazy so I started my journey really
with the natural love of the physical
world so I loved optics light like the
way light travels photography all that
good stuff and I also loved math and so
I just so I got a degree in math
computer science and believe it or not
got a job at Ford Motor Company which
you wouldn't think having a computer
science degree I work at an automotive
but I started writing CAD code and
because I loved geometry and all that
good stuff it led me into that world so
all my time at Ford I never really
worked on a car I was always working on
tech it supported the people that were
developing those cool vehicles and so I
I worked in this paradigm for like lots
of years writing CAD code and then
migrated into more of like the the
process and how you would use the attack
and then started looking at the whole
entire vehicle like chunking it together
and working with the team of people to
develop some ways of making all the
digital day
to make sense to visualize and then from
there I started thinking about virtual
reality and how cool it is yeah take us
take us through some of the the first
times for you of doing the getting
excited about optics getting excited
about math getting excited about writing
CAD code seeing all the data that comes
from that making it applicable in the
design and engineering process tell us
about how all of that works because most
of us get into vehicles we've completely
forgotten about the last hundred years
that has went into the slow but sure
process of making the vehicles more
effective more more safely right hold on
oops moment yes so there is a lot that
goes into making a vehicle a lot of
analytics a lot of thought about the are
the the beautiful curves of surfaces on
the exterior there's a lot that goes
into your experience as a customer like
how are you going to enjoy being in
cabin and what are you gonna do and so
the cool thing about VR and then AR the
whole immersive paradigm is we can
represent all of that together and so
there really isn't a medium that I know
of that represents all of that stuff
puts it in context and then puts you as
the customer at the heart of how you see
all this data so there's analytics for
you know structures like mechanical
things there's packaging things like
zones for like the way those parts move
around and you have to make sure you
have clearance and then there's all
kinds of stuff about found findability
Peugeot reach ability all that kind of
stuff and it's all together in this
immersive environment but back in the
day when I first started doing virtual
reality at Ford it wasn't really ready
for primetime so we could have 60,000
polygons in our entire scene what does
that explain that so that is basically
hardly any
oh sure sure right right so like in this
whole you know whole senior sixty
thousand polygons so just those kind of
well like got little in a 3d environment
so yeah so they're like triangles that
yeah like try strips and so you know a
mesh so a mesh set contains sixty
thousand ships yeah but the thing that's
crazy about that is now we have millions
oh yeah tens of millions like eighty
million you know so the difference is is
stark and the attacker when I first
started working on it was really not
ready for primetime but I could see the
potential in what it had to offer and
I'm always very thankful that Ford let
me do it even though you know when you
think about what I would do to you is I
would say okay Alan I'm gonna strap all
this stuff on your body and from head to
toe Oh back here over here give me this
let me feel that and and it was very
physically invasive to get you in that
environment back in the day and now you
can literally thirty Seconds get
immersed in a scene and explore an
entire vehicle and look at it in context
and it's it's totally great yeah I love
how you speak about the the how the
exponential technology curve affected
the the sixty thousand polygons to tens
of millions of them because the
resolution the amount of data that you
get from that it's just so much greater
and your ability to actually have your
awareness expanded to new ways of
thinking from that higher resolution
because we're such visual creatures so
so then take us through like when you're
you know when you're first starting and
when even at the middle and towards this
end of this you know of the journey with
with Ford and with these with immersive
experiences what were the some of these
most important use cases because it
seems like it can be used for anywhere
from you know the actual
Manufacturing and to be able to have
employees be able to visually see how
they're assembling vehicles but all the
way to like you were saying the customer
the customer is able to see themselves
in the vehicle where they're going to
what was the word you used for how they
interact with the vehicle the goer oh
yeah the ergonomics and how quickly they
can identify how to do certain things
right right so that's a big question so
basically the way I approached bringing
immersive tech to Ford was case by case
and what would happen at the beginning
is I would find a case that somebody
needed to solve so they needed to know
like the the findability and reach
ability of radio controls for a vehicle
and so I'd say I can set that up for you
and you can come and look at it and so
then we would tackle that and then that
would be a use case that people would
say okay that's good I understand in the
beginning they would say that was very
useful but I really don't want to do
that again because you're really
violating myspace putting all this stuff
on me but as technology marched on we
were able to go you know in a move the
tech so that it was less obtrusive and
less like violating your personal space
and then just more value so between the
less feeling like a cyborg and then more
content in it it's really yeah it's so
the good thing was is that as that
progression happened we were able to
take the tech from these singular use
cases and start blending them so then
you could do
Urgo studies along with design because
there could be a instance and there very
often is that a design is really
beautiful but it's not functional so how
do you have each of those people the
artists and the user experience person
and the engine
that designs the underlying components
how do you get them all together so that
they all understand each other's
perspective through immersion it is a
great way of getting people together
when they don't normally understand each
other's perspective because an engineer
comes in with a spreadsheet and then an
artist comes in with a drawing or an
animation of you know a model and then
an ergonomics person comes in with
anthropometry data on people and reach
zones and their their language that they
normally speak is all different but
through immersion you get in you look
around you see in context and you
understand so the answer to your
question was like we started attacking
case by case and then ended up with
blending multiple functions together in
an immersive environment and then you
could really understand each other's
perspective so the real value of the TAC
is as a communication tool I like to say
for people that have unlike minds so
then how would the the the the tool of
immersion immersion experiences be able
to help the artist
ergo ergonomic mr. Ghanim the engineer
communicate so they all are seeing the
same thing which is the vehicle which is
the thing that the customer takes
delivery of and that makes sense to
everybody so no matter what your
perspective is the final result of your
work is the vehicle and you know in the
case of Ford right and so they all
understand what that would look like
they they intimately are familiar with
the final product and so if you
represent all of that data properly in
context put it together then it makes
sense to everybody that's in the room
and and more and that's the thing also
about the tech is you can loop in P
Boal from other locations and have them
see through your eyes and then
understand your context for them
somewhere around the globe and so then
the one of the main will one of the main
ways of the importance of taking these
unlike minds and bringing them together
is that when their processes pre-final
product they're in the process of
deciding where some of these
functionalities go that type of stuff
that they're able to all be in this
immersion Airy experience together where
they're looking at like a simulation of
the final product right and then
determining where it needs to go for
optimal functionality exactly exactly
they can determine where it can go and
then they can cheat the natural world so
I love that about the tech is that so
okay I'm looking at this vehicle and it
looks good but what happens at night
what does it look like does it still
look good if I put like mercury vapor
lights versus you know fluorescent light
model on it what does that do to the
color how does that you know play with
reflections if I am in a cloudy day
situation versus a bright light
situation what does that do if if it's
different times of year and the suns and
different locations so there's all kinds
of lighting things you can do like you
think about the reflections on your side
glass of your like instrument cluster on
the glass can simulate all of those
things in real time and get all this
data that you really couldn't get unless
you literally were at that time at that
you know and those weather conditions
existed or that's good stuff yeah so and
then think about that with options
option a option B I mean that the
ability to to like switch out geometry
switch out where you are what you're
seeing you know what types of analytics
change the the display so that instead
of looking at the beautiful sheet metal
you're looking at lines that show
the surface continuity so now you're
getting analytics then you go back to
what it looks like then you switch paint
colors and you you know using the
natural world that's the way you
describe which is very interesting that
you can really quickly make these
iterations in the design without even
needing to and you can also test the
functionality as so of what it looks
like when it's at night so you're seeing
the function how functional is it still
an eye in with a certain this is this is
cool what is this our immersion
experience is also used in both the the
very early training process of someone
in the manufacturing at Ford is it also
used for them to better understand how
the vehicle is being assembled is it
used at the end of the process for the
customer to be able to immerse
themselves obviously physically in the
vehicle but also virtually potentially
and all in the ways that they can use
all the components of the car yep
absolutely so what's cool is you can
actually get immersed in a sketch
something you a 2d sketch just surround
yourself with it
wrap it on a sphere and get in it and
look around and then start
volumetrically understanding your flat
sketch really early before you've
actually even created geometry you can
do that and then use that paradigm all
the way through the whole process so
like very early on when your ID aiding
and creating like volumes and spaces and
thinking about like the ways in which
people might interact in your vehicle
space that it's just a perfect way to
kind of lay out that the shapes and and
form around the occupants of the vehicle
and with so much going on with
autonomous vehicles there's a lot more
use cases we might be in a situation
where like we are right now looking at
each other and sitting on something that
looks like a nice sofa like this but
taking a ride so how do we interact in
that environment which is different than
the occupants all facing forward
so there's a lot of you know goodness
and trying to understand really early on
how those things are gonna go and then
four chairs pointed towards each exactly
yeah and then moveable maybe they move
like this and maybe they go this way and
you know to your left is the Museum of
Natural History exactly
I mean there's and then what do you do
with all of the space around you this
the surfaces can they now have more than
one function can they have some smarts
in them or you know like I don't know
what they're thinking of but there's a
lot of possibility for how the surfaces
and the interior the vehicle get get
used now so there's four computers hadar
displays or you know all kinds of stuff
and and and then also if you think about
so that's really really early on when
your ID aiding and trying to understand
what what potentially you might want to
develop and then carry that through bed
mode yeah some Lobby relaxing guys yeah
and then fast-forward that through to
the end of the process for like vehicles
that are closer to being produced and
then we can this is I just think this is
amazing we could take the whole
manufacturing process from beginning to
end and come out with the tolerances
they build conditions for every part to
every other part in the vehicle and we
could take that read it in and show it
to you without any pre work done to the
immersive environment and then and then
you could pick any components and then
we could show you with you know the Six
Sigma capability how capable the
manufacturing process would be for the
vehicle that you're looking at and what
is the Six Sigma capability so it's so
most so every car company I'm sure
designs their products around this way
of determining like how accurate you are
so a Sigma like me Sigma and Six Sigma
it's like a way for a way right right
okay and so it's it's basically like how
capable are you so Six Sigma is like the
most the most capable in the process
forming the absolute best right possibly
right and so you know and so you want to
get to Six Sigma capable that way cell
vehicles making it like a hundred
thousand miles and the JD ratings are
off the charts right and the in the
tolerances like the build quality
between the components is tight and
where it should be so it's as designed
not as produced so are they the same are
they different you know
yeah it's that kind of thing so we you
want to be very capable in your
manufacturing process and you want it to
look really good so if you could take
all of that data and and you can
actually watch like one component to
another and move yeah and then they
might move this way they might move
flush like up and down they might move
back and forth but you can actually take
any components like dump all that data
in apply it to the model and then and
then pick things and watch them move and
understand how capable your
manufacturing process is that is really
cool because it applies every like the
whole manufacturing process going
through and and like this get attaches
to this attaches to this and as that
happens there's locators there are other
things that determine there's jigs and
fixtures that measure where you're at
all of that is considered in the end you
get this spreadsheet that tells you how
capable you are but we can take that
spreadsheet and apply it to the geometry
and show it to you in an immersive
environment so you see literally what
the customer would take delivery of not
what was designed and at the peak
capability
of the vehicle as well or not right if
you learning experience yes well what if
you run that analysis and you find that
you're not optimum now what do you do so
now you have a chance to react because
you haven't produced the vehicle yet you
have only predicted what will be but the
the thing about the tak about the
immersive space is it may something that
is the highest tolerance may or may not
look good so because we're there are you
know lighting like tricks with lighting
shadows something might be hidden in
shadow and never be a problem but in the
past we it might have been flagged as a
problem because it didn't meet the
tolerance band that we thought but it
actually it's okay and then other things
may meet the tolerance guidelines and be
spied on and then you look at it and it
looks off compared to the other things
that are around yeah so then there's a
functionality and a aesthetic that is
hopefully an optimal but there are
sometimes trade-offs and they're these
need to be analyzed
exactly interesting now okay what were
some of the other cuz this slowly led
you into wanting to start immersion Airy
your own company what were some of these
other really aha moments for you that
you were like okay we really need to
take my skills and start applying it
around the world and helping people
around the world with this process so a
couple things one is the value of
collaboration in immersive environments
the insight that you get when you're
together with other people and studying
the thing that you're producing is
unlike any other way of understanding
and communicating and the value of all
of the work that I did when I was at
Ford with a team of really great people
by the way nobody does anything by
themselves definitely but the the value
of that and the reason why I was able to
get the company to invest in it was
about collaboration
it was about how people work together
how they share how they can be in the
same location around the world so you
could be in Germany and I could be in
Australia and we could be in the same
immersive environment at the same time
that's really powerful location
agnosticism yes exactly so so that's one
thing another thing is I develop most of
the immersive TAC and without being able
to see it so I was stereo blind and so I
couldn't see in 3d so I was in this 3d
immersive space and developing it and
part of the reason why I got into this
TAC was I knew I was stereo blind and I
studied like what does that mean why
can't I see what everyone else can see
and what's different about what I see
compared to everybody else yeah and I
really enjoyed providing immersive
experiences for people and having them
react even though I couldn't see it so
when somebody would get in and say this
is so cool oh my gosh I would I would
know that I was onto something
yeah but in what you see I would see
it's like if you took your iPad and you
walked around the world that's what I
saw so kind of like flat but dimensional
because it you could move through it so
like a TV but you know you're directing
it yourself so just a flat so like you
would have no dimension to you yeah so
but it but if I turn and I look at you
it'd just be like having the iPad yeah
turning and looking but is it or is it
really locked in that way like for for
all of your sight oh yeah everything
because my eyes were in different planes
and so to form a stereoscopic image your
eyes are I mean they're separated for a
reason
they converge on a point and then your
brain determines how far away that is
and and but mine were like this so I
could never converge on a point so I had
to use this eye or that eye but I
couldn't use them together because they
they literally were physically incapable
of coming together to converge ever on
anything and so in are there advantages
to this as well no gave me headaches it
was I had to concentrate really hard and
like where my eyes were so that they
didn't appear weird to people so I spent
a lot of time like you know moving my
eyes to acceptable place but I had
surgery in 2011 and 2012 that gave me
cereal whoa yeah that thank goodness for
science exactly and that is why I wear
glasses now because it so basically the
surgery was taking my eyeballs out of my
head the actual eyeballs like sucking in
my ho and then disconnecting them like
keeping the optic nerve of course but
like just disconnecting and moving my
eye and then sewing it back together and
then putting it back in my head and
souls yeah and so it had people have it
yeah you know it's very rare when like 2
to 3 percent of the population have it
at birth and that was me people acquire
it through aging that's know quite a lot
of people yeah yeah it is so it they
people are out there they can't see
stereo and you know but I wants the
moment for you when you get back when
you woke up after the surgery and you
were like this is crazy it was instant
it was instant and so what I did before
the surgery my doctor was like you know
Elizabeth you're you're pretty old I'm
not sure we can teach you you get this
old dog a new trick
you know you might we might do the
surgery and you might still have my
revision I'm like well that's okay let's
um can we try so he what he did was he
gave me these glasses that were like
thick prisms and they took my eyes and
they adjusted so that I could form a
stereo image and I went into my car and
I looked at the Ford logo and my
steering wheel like popped out at me
yeah and I just burst into tears like oh
my god should I call him my husband like
like take some time calm down
don't drive but it was it was awesome
but having that experience taught me the
value of immersion in a way deeper sense
than I ever understood and what it
taught me was that aesthetics matter and
little lights and shadows matter and it
is part III see because I didn't have it
for so long and then I had it once I had
it I got back into the immersive
environments and they didn't look right
we're before they actually little better
and I'm like what you know what why do I
think it's not as good and it was all of
the detail that I was now getting about
the lights the way light moves in stereo
in the way it emanates and and so it led
me to do real-time ray tracing and
develop that concept and in getting in
an immersive environment and then you
know being able to slightly move your
head and then see how light is playing
because those sometimes those are
illusions but those illusions are part
of our reality yeah and so between the
there's so much shading right now that's
happening on your face exactly and it's
very important right it's nuanced it's
very beautiful that we've taken this
long period of evolution to be able to
see
that nuance and all facial expression
all lights and shadow effects and this
is a crucial for immersion and
experience exactly exactly and but yet
they're usually absent and just until
recently the ray-tracing is kind of
coming into its own
but back in 2014 I was just like
determined to make it happen and so we
at Ford they that was another investment
thing and they they invested in some
tech and we were able to do real-time
rate racing in 4k and so that was an
industry-first and it just showed the
power of what it really should look like
and so your question why you know why
did I feel I needed to go out on my own
I think that the time is now to develop
standards for how we work how we realize
like cross-functional collaborative
communication in immersive environments
and I think that the technology has come
into its own and with innovations and AI
using AI for ray tracing like doing
that's called denoising which means like
kind of getting rid of the clutter in
the environment and kind of making some
assumptions about what the images should
look like that is really really cool
tech and so it's taking it from
large-scale supercomputers and making it
more useful and then in enterprise
that's that's what they do they
communicate they talk they share they
they make something and then if you make
something then you really want to see it
before you make it and then see it
properly as the customer would see it
before they take delivery of it these
this your push for for these new
standards in immersion experiences is
really cool to be able to now unpack
with you what are some of the the
standards you're talking about location
agnosticism so
people from around the world can
collaborate in the same immersive
environment what does the the version
control look like what does the engineer
how do engineering simulations make
their way into these environments how
does that actually turn into you know
final products and data AI cloud all
these types of things that are involved
in this process what does what about
your ideal standards for immersive
environments so the immersive
environments specifically for enterprise
yes really require discipline and the
the the thing about immersive tech is
you might see a really cool demo but
it's a one-off and so is it part of how
the enterprise works maybe maybe not but
this is a really good application of
immersive tech works how the enterprise
functions it works with how they produce
their data
it works with how they like their
milestones and how they do their process
like for the development of their tech
it works with the the multitudes of data
that they produce so some is analytics
so like CAE computer-aided engineering
work like stress and load and weight
cost information like all of this other
ancillary data that's different than the
CAD data that is produced to engineer
the parts there's a lot of data yes and
if it all is they every Enterprise knows
their process really well they have this
well-oiled machine to get to the final
product but where a good implementation
of immersion takes that data and lays a
foundation and then feeds the immersive
environment at different points in the
process so that you're working how the
enterprise works and you're not
retrofitting the VR tech to the process
so in other words if you start breaking
that chain
it adds time it adds cost and nobody
wants to do it so they might do it once
but they're not gonna do it all the time
so you really need to fit in to how the
enterprise functions and then provide
them the capability to assess their data
in the way that they are used to
assessing it not in the way that the
software has like whatever choices that
your rendering software has that's not
good enough it's you don't want that you
want what they do so what would be
examples of the way that enterprises
would want to use the mercenary
experiences in with the way that they
could continue to use the data in the
way that they're used to how would how
what would these use cases look like for
the new enterprises that you'll be
working with so one would be really
about manufacturing so taking the
manufacturing process like I talked
about earlier and applying it to the
design and then showing what that those
build conditions would look like that's
one another one would be if you're
designing a product and you have to rely
on somebody's like somebody operating
the your product you need to know that
the the vision zones are good and that
they can you know under reach the things
that they need to and that's analytical
information that is developed by other
software's but you would actually need
to see the the vision zones kind of come
into your immersive environment to make
sure that that is you can see and you
can reach and you can understand so
that's more analytical information in
that environment you might have quality
data that represents like some potential
damage that might happen so you know
every every company wants to make sure
that their quality is really high that
their products
and then some of the things that are
could be damaged you might never
perceive like a slight bending and apart
you know that so you can represent that
in the immersive environment so that's
analytical information that actually
morphs the geometry puts like they may
be a slight bend or a dimple in
something and then you can look at it
and say I can't even see that I've
retraced it I've looked at it from up
close and far away I've looked at a day
and night and it looks fine so it's
really getting all of this data from all
of these different sources into the
model and then showing it as it would
look if a customer was interfacing with
it
okay so then this is like the merge the
missionary experiences are at this
entire process of the product lifecycle
management there throughout the whole
process and then and then I would you
say that what is now the cutting edge
and where is it going with the virtual
reality or augmented reality how is
Australia person and Germany person in
the same environment doing all the
things that you're listing there what
tech yeah through mostly VR so and you
know wearing a headset being in a
virtual space and then having locations
known of where you are in the
environment so even though you're in
Australia we would know where you were
with respect to this couch yes and I'm
in Germany and you know where I am with
respect and so I would see your headset
floating in space and you would see mine
and we could collaborate yeah I think a
lot of the innovations in this space are
really going to be through storytelling
and providing an actionable way of you
to experience the world so we're we have
now a lot of potential if we do the hard
work and we have a platform and a
pipeline of getting a lot of the
different information into those models
like we just talked about
but what's new is getting data in so
that you can control your destiny so you
can have an experience with the product
so if you're on a plane and you sit down
in your seat and you're in you know
you're blessed with first class you can
kind of recline your seat and turn your
display on and reach for this and that
and all of the things around you are
actionable so you can do them you can
interact with them the way you want to
not the way somebody told you to or not
in a way that is a one-off because you
have this like game controller in your
hand and you're like pressing this
button doing that instead you just make
things happen and then you so so it's
taking the physical world putting it
together with the virtual world but the
physical world is actually just a
representation in very like minimal form
of what you're studying and then but
when you're in the immersed in it it
appears to you that you are fully in the
physical world and then you can start
interacting so doing a lot with
actionable haptics that are passive so
that you can actually feel and touch and
then kind of control your destiny tell a
story really get it that use user
experience and then that includes
integration with like 3d printing
you know like smart 3d printed objects
that actually have microcontrollers
embedded in them so they function in the
virtual world and then do more with like
where you place those things and how
they operate and then the other big
thing I would say that's coming is
really like training models in AI so
you're looking at things and then while
you're assessing your product you're
learning yeah and then while you're
assessing your product somebody
you know somebody the cloud is in
contacts presenting you with relevant
information yeah a lot about how the
functionality or about the aesthetic and
all these other types of data points
that are really important and you're
there with another person from another
country looking at it and talking about
what you're learning about what you're
designing and engineering even pre
manufacturing so you don't make loops of
saving lots of money this way this is
like this is kind of like the dollars
and cents side of things that companies
that's why there's a lot of investment
into the space because they know there's
a lot of oopss that cost lots of money
and save on that yep interesting I like
the I like the idea of storytelling a
lot that that is one of the it always
takes me to this like big history
perspective on civilization a lot of a
lot of I think of the roots of the
malevolence as that happen is because we
potentially did not do a good job at
explaining you know how we birth from
the cosmos now it's such a it's such a
you know such a blissful ecstatic
experience that we get to even live on
this earth together and so if we if we
could do our best to make these
immersive experiences that get people's
awareness from birth to understand that
this is such a whole experience for all
of us including a mother earth and all
of its biosphere that that that is those
these are the immersive experiences that
I'm also as well as all the
manufacturing design yeah yeah there's
like yeah there's some other really
powerful immersive experiences I'm very
excited for as well
Elizabeth any other thoughts that you
think we may have missed that you think
are important to cover so I'm the
experienced immersive experiences in the
end we are all emotional creatures that
use our minds eye to figure out what we
see in our world so we we our brain
stitches together image
and makes things appear to us for our
reality but our brains are always
involved in what we see because our our
visual acuity is actually like this two
degree field of view and then our brain
is putting together all the things we
see so the reason why I bring that up is
because our brains are involved in how
we see the world it is that means that
we have the capability for insight and
we even though we see things we may look
at a spreadsheet and like look at data
and think that's just data when you see
it applied it's a different set of data
it's the same set of data but it appears
different to us because now it's in
context and it it has meaning and all of
the things that go with being part of a
you know a person of Earth here they all
kind of come out and that's what I think
the value of immersion is it allows you
to see it in context use your insight
and in really form use your mind's eye
and understand something completely and
it gives you such a better connection to
your end customer whoever that is that
you wouldn't have in any other way yeah
yeah that's so so important and the
looking at it on a you know on a like a
70 year timeline just going from such a
flat pixelated to the surface - no - now
the full 3d indistinguishable virtual
realities that that and augmented
reality is that that is that is so
profoundly it's it's a to much different
experience for our brain stage with the
last second two years ago right
we were yeah and there's so much promise
coming with air I'm really excited yeah
where that's going - yeah I hope it has
a lot of especially focus and potential
on all of the retraining that that we
need for the automation and AI robotics
age
yes yes there are so many jobs opening
up that we need to retrain for these
there's a new job
yes yes it was what this has been such a
pleasure appreciate you asking thank you
yeah thank you you're really pushing
forward some really important topics and
it's been such a pleasure thank you
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate you we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below let us
know what you're thinking
go and share these conversations about
these immersion Airi experiences the
importance of them with your communities
with your friends your families on the
Internet go and share support the
artists and entrepreneurs that you
believe in support Kofi's support
Elizabeth all their links are below
once the support simulation our links
are below as well and go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world we love you very much
thank you for tuning in and we will see
you soon